this dick man is being drawn by South
Korean doodler Kim Jung Joo and it's
left over three million people online
saying seriously brought to life by the
power of water
he became an acrobats yes just by adding
water
Kim stick man comes to life this is so
incredible how cool is this so what's
the secret behind this magic marker the
stick man is drawn on a glassy surface
using a dry white marker the dry white
markers ink is made of ethanol and
propanol which are both alcohols a color
pigment and what's called a release
agent which is what allows it to be
wiped off so easily
when you use a dry white marker the
alcohol in the ink quickly evaporates
off leaving behind the release agent and
the color pigments when water is added
these don't read a salt into the water
and so the ink is able to hold its shape
the release agent is made of silicon
oils so when the water hits the stick
man the oils in the water don't mix and
the water slides right underneath the
stick for this trick to work the ink
must be put onto a smooth non-porous
surface because there are no pores for
the ink to sink down into it sits on the
top and can float up really easily and
then all Kim has to do is blow on it to
start it dancing and that's the story of
the stick figure that became a real boy
[Music]